in the 12th year of our marriage Carl
and I decided that I was going to have
multiple partners because I had met and
fallen for another guy so I came back
and reported that to Carl so we decided
to talk about it like what do we do how
do we go about this and that began a
two-year journey of Ken and I just kind
of discussing things we just had to
figure things out so we discussed it for
a number of years I finally came into
the knowledge and understanding about
feminine you know expression and realize
you have to allow women to be free and
express themselves and as a man I just
support her in doing that
tiger a Halloween party he was dressed
as Tiger Woods and he was looking hot
and sexy well I came out and uh had a
dance with you so we had a nice little
romantic slow dance it was real nice yes
and so I decided you know I'm going to
pursue this I'm going to see where this
leads to right so those just go right up
there and then the green painting goes
in the center all right I'm super
multifaceted it feels like Carl fits one
part of who I am philosophical and
spiritual and oh we have these deep
conversations and then the other part is
like thrill seeking excitement traveling
and that's who tiger fits but I'm both
of those people in one body so I like to
have those multiple Partnerships is it
one nail for each pain oh it's probably
gonna be two let's do the big painting
first we're all basically Trailblazers
in this way and we all support each
other that's why why I'm so ready to
support tiger and Kenny whenever they
need support in their relationship or
anything else I think a lot of what
people see on the day-to-day is kind of
like the whys why would anybody do that
why would that man invite you into his
house and have you with his wife why
it's a benefit to have another person
there as a benefit to have somebody that
you can kind of relate to that you can
trust versus just having some random
person come in or cheating cheating just
lying hiding it really adds a lot of
Serenity to the home a lot of guys that
I meet are you know I always start out
by telling guys that I meet
I already am in two long-term marriages
how do they react to that
most react well
dating because I'll always be dating
it's just
it's fake it's hard to explain this
because it feels like this is not rocket
science we all love attention energy
relationships and love
[Music]